bienvenido a france 24 y cuéntenos señor
lópez el tribunal supremo electoral
anunció ayer la suspensión del sistema
de conteo rápido directo que cuéntenos
qué impacto tiene esta decisión en la
credibilidad de los resultados finales y
también que tanto tendrán que esperar
los bolivianos para saber quién será su
nuevo presidente las elecciones que
tienen lugar hoy
nuevas noches el impacto sobre la
credibilidad
es positivo diría yo porque resulta que
este diré que usted menciona es un
sistema de conteo rápido de votos que
alcanza aproximadamente al 90 95 por
ciento de las actas escrutadas el
problema o la raíz de la decisión del
tribunal tiene que ver con la mínima
distancia que existe entre las
candidaturas la primera y la segunda y
la experiencia del año pasado en la
elección anulada
dada la elección anulada y lo que le
comentó la posibilidad de que el cierre
de la elección sea muy reñida el
tribunal decide cortar porque porque
probablemente como es una especie de
encuesta este sistema de conteo rápido
es probable que tenga un margen de error
y si el margen de error es
pequeño pero grande dadas las
condiciones de la elección actual podría
cuestionarse la fiabilidad de este
sistema si nuevamente abonar una
narración sobre un fraude electoral para
evitar esto el tribunal decide eliminar
el sistema de conteo rápido para más
bien garantizar y acudir únicamente al
cómputo oficial es decir los resultados
escrutados de forma oficial esa es la
razón de la eliminación de este sistema
de conteo sí señor pedimos hoy una
jornada electoral pacífica pero en un
ambiente tan polarizado también y
cuéntanos usted qué tan probable es que
las partes acepten el resultado final
habrá una segunda vuelta y también si se
evitará una segunda espiral de violencia
como la vivida en 2019
es muy probable muchas organizaciones
han pedido y han construido un acuerdo
de las candidaturas para que estos
llegan públicamente que van a aceptar
los resultados en su gran mayoría las
candidaturas han expresado que van a
aceptar los resultados
el tribunal electoral es ampliamente
confiable en la ciudadanía entonces en
mi estimación es que la posibilidad de
hechos de violencia van a ser muchísimo
menores a los ocurridos el año pasado y
la aceptación de los resultados en
consecuencia tiene una alta probabilidad
por supuesto que existe también una
posibilidad de que el partido que pierda
pueda propiciar hechos de violencia
particularmente uno de ellos queda en
semanas pasadas ha anunciado que en caso
de que ellos no ganen como reflejan las
encuestas sería públicamente por un
fraude electoral y habría una
movilización masiva pero creo que a
estas alturas la madurez de la
ciudadanía ha puesto una especie de
freno a esta posibilidad de una salida
más violenta a la elección